86 l'année du cinéma c'est l'occasion ou
jamais de célébrer le 7e art car le
cinéma cette année à 90 ans et la
cinémathèque créé par henri langlois
fête ses 50 ans sans demi siècle alors
pour célébrer tout cela eh bien nous
avons demandé à pierre tchernia
spécialiste s'il en est de nous
concocter une page spéciale d'antenne de
midi en direct de la cinémathèque
bonjour pierre
vous êtes donc à la cinémathèque et
j'aperçois déjà autour de vous un
certain nombre de choses des éléments
historiques fort intéressant louis hervé
je suis au musée du cinéma
et puisque nous parlons à la fois de ce
90ème anniversaire du cinématographe et
du 50e anniversaire de la cinémathèque
et bien voici une des premières caméras
louis lumière enfin une caméra des
frères lumière puisqu'il signait tous
les deux leur invention
je suis dans le musée du cinéma et comme
votre émission est extrêmement regarder
j'en profite pour dire à tous les
amateurs de cinéma que le musée du
cinéma il est à paris qu on y entre par
l'entrée du musée des monuments français
au palais de chaillot et que tous les
jours sauf le mardi
eh bien il ya des visites groupées à 10h
à 11h à 14h à 15h à 16h c'est un musée
où il y a cinq mille pièces présentées
et 45000 en réserve
c'est un musée qui s'étend sur 15 cents
mètres carrés s'est amusé dans lequel on
peut vivre l'aventuré du cinéma d'une
façon étonnante au travers d' affiches
d'objets et de costumes car là nous
sommes dans les salles réservées aux aux
débuts du cinéma mais il ya par exemple
une robe d'autant en emporte le vent
une rolls non une robe de de martine
carol dans le las montès et bien ce
musée du cinéma il est l'aboutissement
du travail de la cinémathèque
il était l'un des rêves d'henri langlois
car effectivement pierre si un homme
dont il faut parler toujours à propos de
la cinémathèque c'est bien le créateur
c'est henri langlois henri langlois un
homme
passionné de cinéma un homme qui a eu le
premier l'idée d'aller à fait un peu
partout des bobines et de et de les
cacher dans les baignoires de ses amis
c'est une légende mais je crois qu'elle
est un peu vrai cette légende au travers
de mille difficultés dès 1936 avec ses
amis comme jean mitry ou georges franju
passionné de cinéma il a voulu le
montrer le montrer le plus possible et
c'est au travers de ses efforts
considérables qui ont été faits à cette
époque que la cinémathèque vit
aujourd'hui est que la cinémathèque que
peut présenter 200 séances par mois que
la séance que la cinémathèque vie avec
un fonds de 40 mille films que la
cinémathèque peut faire des
rétrospectives des éditions et offrir un
public de fanatiques toutes les
occasions de découvrir ou de redécouvrir
le cinéma
mariez vous parliez pierre des du fonds
de la cinémathèque c'est très important
je crois vous disiez vous citiez un
chiffre crois qu'il est bon de revenir
sur ce fond car l'une des activités de
la cinémathèque c'est le stockage des
films combien il ya de films alors il
vient des bobines
il y à il ya quarante mille films bon
chaque chine représente environ 10
bobines de 300 mètres fait la
multiplication aller simple mais ici au
palais de chaillot c'est-à-dire à côté
de la salle de projection c'est qu'il ya
deux lieux de projection il ya le centre
pompidou et le palais de chaillot
il y as uniquement les films qui sont
tant qu'ils sont de passage les bobines
qui reviennent les bobines qui partent
mais tout ça bien sûr se retrouvent dans
les réserves de la cinémathèque qui se
trouve à bois d'arcy fait et c'est ici
qu'il y à aussi je vous disais qu'il ya
5000 objets je voudrais qu'on termine
mes wc à notre panoramique dans cette
salle parce qu'elle est consacrée à
méliès et pourquoi j'y tiens c'est parce
que si on est au 90ème anniversaire du
cinéma depuis le 28 décembre
en 96 on va être au 90e anniversaire des
premiers films de méliès génial
inventeur du spectacle cinématographique
non seulement en france mais dans le
monde méliès dont on ne dira jamais trop
de bien merci pierre pour l'instant nous
vous retrouvons dans un instant car vous
avez parlé des différentes activités de
la cinémathèque il y a donc le stockage
c'est très important
il y a le fait de montrer les films en
permanence
ce que les amateurs peuvent aller voir
dans les différentes salles de
projection et puis il y à aussi la
restauration des films car les teens est
une denrée périssable les vieux films
il faut les restaurer c'est un travail
difficile qui est effectuée aussi à bois
d'arcy par un laboratoire spécialisé
jacques violet il a fait un reportage
fort intéressant regardez
sans les archives de bois d'arcy ce
document exceptionnel n'existerait pas
la première opération chirurgicale filmé
à l'hôpital de la salpêtrière en 1902
des chirurgies un barbu en simple
tablier blanc sans masque et sans gants
ce document comme des centaines d'autres
qui sont la mémoire du cinéma français
ou du moins ce qu'il en reste puisque
l'on estime que 60% de la production
française a disparu arrive au service
des archives
installé dans l'ancien fort militaire de
bois d'arcy dans un état pitoyable
quelquefois à la limite du sauvetage
possible pour les plus anciens les films
qui entre ici qu'ils soient anciens ou
récents sont déposés par différentes
personnes et organismes plus de 1000
déposant pour y être stocké et entretenu
eh bien nous avons de peu près de 105
millions de m de films
environ 85 me le titre pas loin de 800
mille bobine
c'est à dire en gros si vous voulez 16
ans de projections continuent en quatre
heures sur 24 à 24 images seconde et
toutes ses archives appartiennent tech
qui est bien elles sont de différentes
provenances d'organismes publics mais
aussi des deux producteurs des
distributeurs de collectionneurs de
laboratoire et d'associations diverses
pour les films qui date d'avant 1953 qui
sont sur un support de nitrate de
cellulose pratiquement voué à l'auto
destruction chimique
commence alors le sauvetage et la
restauration on essaiera par tous les
moyens possible de stopper la
destruction dans les laboratoires les
doigts de fée des techniciens vont se
promener le long de ses trésors vérifier
nettoyez-les avait reconstitué des
perforations manquantes image par image
ces kilomètres de pellicule seront
sauvés
ensuite il faudra procéder à
l'étalonnage préparer le film resterait
pour pouvoir en tirer la meilleure copie
possible un contretype qui s'approchera
avec la plus grande fidélité de
l'original là encore avec un soin
constant toujours image par image
cette machine var filmer le document
restaurer
et c'est ensuite le stockage dans ces
grands bâtiments installés dans les
fossés du fort militaire s'il s'agit
d'un support moderne des films de
sécurité dans ces bâtiments construits
en paroisse isotherme et revêtement
d'aluminium pour les anciens films en
nitrates plus fragiles et plus l'enjoint
puisque inflammable toutes les boîtes
sont rouges
ils seront isolés dans des cellules pour
des raisons de sécurité ici l'on
contrôler l'humidité et la température
intérieure qui doit être constante c'est
là derrière ses portes que sont stockés
entreposées les archives de la
cinémathèque française qui sont en
revanche entretenu et restauré dans
d'autres laboratoires à bois d'arcy
le premier souci est de sauvegarder
toute la mémoire du cinéma sans a priori
esthétique de septième art fait
aujourd'hui partie intégrante de notre
patrimoine culturel
quel travail en tout cas pierre tchernia
pour fêter ce 50e anniversaire on va
vous retrouver car car je crois qui
mérite effectivement d'être célébré et
dans vos recherches pierre vous avez
trouvé un objet en germe regarde c'est
une affiche enfin la comète
c'est un film de 1910 c'est à dire il ya
76 ans à la même langue mais d'aller à
la comète de halley parfait puisque
c'est une dame qui ne vient nous voir
que tous les 76 ans alors qu'hier oui ce
qui est important c'est pareil
maintenant de l'avenir de la
cinémathèque les questions qui se posent
l'avenir de la cinémathèque on va en
parler avec costa gavras puisqu'il se
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
c'est un grand cinéaste qui est en même
temps le président de la cinémathèque
française chère costa gavras je sais que
vous êtes très pris par le montage d'un
film mais vous trouvez le temps de
consacrer le temps qu'il faut bien sûr à
la cinémathèque et à ce 50e anniversaire
ce qui me paraît intéressant c'est de
savoir ce que pour vous va devenir la
cinémathèque quels sont les quels sont
les nouveaux les nouvelles marches que
vous voulez gravir base la prochaine
étape a pour nous tous ici c'est de
trouver de nouveaux locaux plutôt
d'aller aux nouveaux locaux qui nous ont
été promis par les gouvernements c'est à
dire au palais de tokyo pour pouvoir
d'abord rire tous les services agrandir
le musée fin de nouvelles salles
beaucoup plus grande beaucoup plus belle
et plusieurs sade faire la bibliothèque
et le centre de documentation que nous
avons ici mais qui dès finalement
complètement étouffé par le nombre de
gens qui veulent y accéder donc c'est
une c'est une étape pour les années à
venir qui va s'ouvrir plus à la
profession et plus la république mais on
sait où vous allez allez on est les
vieux au palais de tokyo
c'est sûr je crois pouvoir dire que
c'est c'est en haute de se faire moi je
voudrais vous poser deux questions très
rapide costa gavras parce que
malheureusement on arrive au terme de
cette émission est telle séquence qui
est vraiment passionnante ya le problème
financier aussi je sais que les crédits
de la cinémathèque ont été multipliés
par trois des choses comme ça dans un
certain parfum il passe l'été encore en
dessous de la vérité mais est-ce que ça
va continuer est-ce que avec par exemple
un autre gouvernement vous êtes
optimiste pessimiste pour la suite mais
je suis optimiste la cinémathèque ce
n'est pas une affaire de gouvernement
c'est une affaire de la france je pense
que de cinéma appartient à tout le monde
et que la cinémathèque appartient à tout
le monde aussi donc quel que soit le
gouvernement
les crédits devraient se poursuivre et
l'augmenter sûrement et puis une
question qui me tracasse envoyant
notamment leur portage tout à l'heure de
jacques violet on se demande un petit
peu avec le progrès avec les vidéos
disent que tout ça est ce que la
cinémathèque et pas appelé à se
transformer complètement en tout cas en
tout cas la vidéo disque peut jouer dans
les années à venir un rôle important
dans la conservation des films et dallas
dans la présentation du film au
chercheur public le plus large possible
mais pour le moment ne sont pas arrivés
encore avoir un disque qui qui gardent
les films sur lesquels ont inscrit des
films et qui rend show pellicule la même
qualité nous sommes encore à la période
de la première étape c'est à dire on
peut se créer le film sur un disque
enregistré sur un disque mais on peut
pas le vrai réenregistrer sur au film et
bien cette étape franchie ça sera très
essentiel mais son tarif sera l'étape de
l'enregistrement numérique qui serait
trop long d'expliquer ici mais ce sera
l'occasion de refaire une autre émission
pourquoi pas pierre en tout cas merci
costa gavras
merci pierre nous sommes obligés
d'arrêter là car il ya malheureusement
beaucoup d'informations encore à donner
dans ce journal
merci beaucoup pierre pour cette visite
guidée de la cinémathèque c'était
passionnant je vous en prie au revoir au
revoir à bientôt pierre tchernia oui
effectivement